welcome to the edge this is certifiably
the greenest office building in the
world but that just might be the least
interesting part about it because the
edge and Amsterdam is also possibly the
most connected office space in the world
working at the edge is insane it all
starts with a smartphone app developed
by the building's main tenant the
consulting firm Deloitte when you arrive
at the edge a camera recognizes you by
your license plate for automatic access
and because it's the Netherlands there
are chargers available for electric cars
inside things start to get interesting
because you don't have a desk no one
here does workspaces are assigned to you
based on your schedule for the day you
have options a work booth a meeting room
what they call a concentration room a
sitting desk a standing desk a balcony
desk you can even just hang out in the
Sun field atrium all day this concept is
called hot desking and it's what allows
Deloitte to have 2,500 workers but less
than half as many desks at its Dutch
headquarters the app knows your
preferences and when you arrive at your
workspace the lights dim or brighten
based on your stored settings and any of
the buildings massive flat screens can
be instantly paired with an iPhone or a
laptop
so what makes all this possible the LED
light panels developed by Philips
specifically for the edge are actually
powered by low voltage ethernet cables
which means every light in the building
becomes its own internet connected data
hub with 28,000 sensors that makes the
building and its users smarter the
building becomes a very important part
of who we are and what we want to be and
we actually seen in recruitment that
more people are now spontaneously coming
to the loyd because they want to work in
this building oh yeah and then there's
these the building has solar on the roof
and on the south-facing wall enough to
power the building and all of the
electric cars computers and smartphones
used by its employees and those
employees are kept warm by two enormous
bore holes tunneling more than four
hundred feet down beneath the building
during the summer the edge pumps warm
water deep into the aquifer where it's
it's insulated until it can be sucked
back out in a winter to warm the
building outside there are beehive
towers and bat homes to support the
local pollinators and even the rainwater
is collected to flush the toilets and
irrigate the gardens we are planning to
build a lot more buildings like these
and the next one will be smarter and the
one after that will be smarter as well
and we won't stop until all cities in
the world are filled with buildings that
are intelligent and that are not using
any energy
more in the end we will actually need
less buildings in the world but the
buildings that are there will be used in
a better way will be more efficient and
will be will be using a lot less energy
than in the past
sometimes the edge just feels like it's
showing off and some of the app
functionality isn't quite ready for
primetime yet but most of the time this
is all running seamlessly in the
background it's maybe the most fully
realized vision of the Internet of
Things the world has ever seen
it's a building that has sustainability
as an important aspect of making a good
place to work in Dutch there is even the
word for this new kind of thinking about
the workspace of new American
in a nutshell it means that work space
is more focused on the tasks that need
to be done and the working community
that it's spot on
another day at the edge comes to an end
a custom security robot that looks a bit
like r2d2 wakes up and begins its
patrols now if only the app could
automatically come conjure up a nice
dinner recipe maybe provide all the
fresh ingredients at the end of the day
to get you cooking no surprise the edge
has that - Bon Appetit
you